we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 david p
uh here is a um a comment about the
recent
mass shootings and joe biden hey david
jerry calling from san antonio
right i was just curious how long do you
think it'll be before
the 21 year old syrian born shooter mass
shooter in colorado who killed 10 people
will be blamed on joe biden's airstrikes
in syria
i haven't heard it blamed on biden's
syrian airstrikes yet doesn't mean it
won't be
but i have already seen um
biden wanting to take guns is
responsible for the shootings and i
don't even i didn't even
maybe i'm too stupid maybe the problem
is me i didn't understand the connection
but i saw that biden's anti-gun agenda
is to blame for the shootings also since
so so right-wing media already was
undercovering
the shooting in georgia because it was a
white perpetrator
who uh killed asian people a lot of the
right-wing net networks ignored that
altogether or barely mentioned it
now that we know the shooter um
in colorado is muslim right-wing
networks are going absolutely completely
bonkers falling over themselves to talk
about that
while still barely mentioning the one
from days before so
everybody is doing exactly what we would
expect them to do
maybe the syrian airstrikes will be
pointed to as the reason why this
shooting took place although i haven't
heard it yet
we have a great bonus show for you today
oakland is launching a guaranteed pay
plan for low-income
people very interesting idea the south
dakota governor
is trying to block trans athletes from
women's sports not just in south dakota
but nationally
howe will explain it and unfortunately
roads are getting deadlier
for pedestrians it's not just drivers
who are seeing an increased
rate of fatalities over the last year it
is also pedestrians and we will talk
about
that on today's bonus show as well
how do you get the bonus show really
easy go to joinpakman.com and sign up
that's it
go to joinpakman.com and sign up you'll
get instant
access to the membership benefits which
include
commercial free audio and video streams
of the show as well as the daily bonus
show
you can use the coupon code better21 if
you want a discount
don't feel obligated and you can also
get bonus show access
by becoming a patron at patreon.com
davidpakmanshow i will see you then
we're back tomorrow we're back friday
then we are
off for a week just a reminder we'll be
off next week